الاخطاء التحكيميه جزء من اللعبه ومتحد
كره القدم هكذا يقول البعض لكن بالطب
يقولون ذلك عندما يفوز الفريق الذي
يشجعونه لكن عندما تحدث اخطاء في الجانب
الاخر لا تصبح الاخطاء متعه بل شبه جريمه
دوليه هناك في الواقع الكثير من الجدل على
مستوى التحكيم والاخطاء منذ بدايه كاس
العالم لكن الدور ربع النهائي شهد حاله
قياسيه من التذمر وشكوى واللاعبين
والمدربين حكم لقاء هولندا والارجنتين رفع
ثمن 10 بطاقه صفراء في اجواء مشخونه داخل
وخارج الملعب الغريب ان لاعبي الفريقين
خرجوا بعد المباراه لينتقدوه في البرتغال
يتعجب اللاعبون من تعيين حكم من ارجنتينيه
في لقائهم امام المغرب اما المنتخب الاسود
الثلاثه يصف الحكم البرازيلي الذي دار
لقاءهم بمنتخب فرنسا بانه سيئ جدا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التحكيم في رايي الشخصي وتعتبروه مجرد راي
شخصي الحكم ضحيه مدير فني لم يتمكن من وضع
التكتيك المناسب ضحيه لاعب لم يوفق في
تسجيل هدف ضحيه ميديا انا اعمل في الميديا
ومش سر انا بقوله الميديا حينما تكون ضد
الحكم فهي اكثر جاذبيه لانها تخاطب عقل
الجمهور
وعاطفه الجمهور الجمهور بطبيعته بيبحث عن
مبرر كل مبررات العالم قبل ان يقول ان
منتخبي او فريقي لم يكن جيدا
هو الحكم فاسمحوني انا يعني واحد من الناس
متعاطف مع التحكيم والحكام لكن اذا تناول
22 بشكل محدد انا باشوف انه اجمالا جيد ما
فيش حالات تحكيميه نقدر نقول انها غيرت
مسار مباريات
من يقرر اذا اخطا الحكم في تحكيمه ومن
يحاسب خصوصا عندما نتحدث عن مباريات مصريه
يعني كاس العالم تحديدا على راس لجنه
التحكيم اهم واحد خلينا نقول مش اهم واحد
من اهم الحكام في تاريخ كره القدم باللي
وجه كولينا الحكم الايطالي واعتقد انه بذل
كل اللي ما بيشتغلش مع الفيفا على فكره
انا باقول كلام في حر يعني الكولينا بذل
جهد غير عادي قبل بدايه المونديال واثناء
المونديال مساله الاعداد مساله الاختيار
بناء على الكفاءه سيمينارز سبقت كاس
العالم وتدريب في اعلى مستوياته لكي يضمن
واستخدام التقنيه ايضا يعني اكثر بطوله في
تاريخ كاس العالم كان فيها استخدام تقنيه
هي مونديال قطره 22 مساله من يحاسب هو
بالتاكيد لجنه الحكام وافضل ان يحاسبه
لجنه الحكام او جهه رسميه وبيتم استبعاد
الحكام من غير موفقين والابقاء على الحكام
الجايين للمراحل